the movie feels like it's really pays
homage to like
those summertime friendships that great
time take me back
you're a kid what's your favorite memory
about being a kid with your friends in
the summer
hot hot hot summer you have to be in a
pool
and have ice cream standing by popsicles
standing by
and goofing off till
like it's so late that you have
you have to get dragged home i think
there is
that um there was that
nomadic spirit of uh
this summer where you didn't really have
a plan
you were just with your friends and you
know you could
say that you're just gonna end up in
trouble but like
there was no supervision so there was
just kind of
filling your day that i think is
as adults we try and recreate when we go
on vacations
but we fail there's going to be land
monsters everywhere
it's me you scared the scales off of me
you're strong i'm sorry i'm just a
little on edge no i needed that
it really woke me up it's like we've
lost it and we can never
re-grasp what it is to be on vacation as
a kid again
yeah um tell me about friends right
so friends are important uh what's
a characteristic that you must check off
in order to be in a friendship with
somebody you have to
you have to um not interrupt maya
i think you have to also i'm not
somebody who uh like the friends things
are important
are you have to be good-looking be
rich you have to be um
you have to have fancy things
no i think uh it's you know
i think the most important trait is
that even as people evolve and change
and i think
this movie captures it so much uh
because there is that ever existing
affinity you have for the person even if
you don't have
anything in common with that person
anymore like i know that
one of my great friends is uh he's a
doctor in maine
and you know you know but we were these
kids
in indiana at the age of you know 12
saying that we had these dreams so like
it's that
even how different our lives are we
still have that i mean he's
he's never met me but i have it
but also that you probably when you're
with those friends
that you've known since you were a kid
or you you pick up right where you left
off
yeah yeah that's the best we do not go
anywhere near the surface got it
everything good is above the surface
walking air the sky
clouds the sun whoa don't look at it
just kidding definitely look at it you
guys tell me a little bit about
the the movie touches on you know the
age-old rule the age-old uh you know
your parents always tell us not to do
something and what do we do we
immediately go do it so luca
not supposed to do something he goes and
does it
what did your parents do what do you
remember specifically
doing when your parents told you not to
do
oh boy what didn't i do
yeah what didn't you do like don't touch
that kind of stuff
like that's hot don't touch that and
then i touched it
like don't hit your brother and then you
hate your brother
don't don't murder people you murder
people i tried not to do that
i i was i was raised kind of
to seek um to pursue
security like my father was the first
one to go to college so
the the entertainment industry was
there was just too many risks associated
with
it uh there was no job security my dad
actually was a
a musician and he told me to never um
he didn't want me to marry a guitar
player
that's good advice so is it
i mean some guitar players might make
really good partners in crime i don't
know
i think he knew what he was talking
about right
yeah i think he said it for a reason did
you guys practice that head scratch
because you just did it in tandem
it was no we didn't but i saw it and i
was so into it
but i didn't know if you saw it in the
same way because like we're all lined up
differently right
yeah i can tell you e.t is going to use
the bite of both of your arms going off
at the same time for sure
that we you know when you work together
with someone
and we've we've done hours of mirroring
exercises yeah and there is a
certain there's a uh
there's a cohesion here i mean
yeah i will just call
maya in the middle of the night and
she'll be like why are you calling and i
was like
just run to check in so that we can
practice our
sometimes often we will finish each
other's
sandwiches and sentences
maya talk to me a little bit about
playing a villain
disenchanted if you dare um
i'm very excited about it yeah i mean
that's like
that's g that's juicy town usa like
when you know when you're when you're a
kid and you're like you're the villain
you're like come on i want to be the
princess but then when you get older
you're like yeah the villain is
fun please tell me please i beg you
lie to me if it's not true do i please
get a song and dance like a big villain
song and dance
i don't know are you into songs and
dances i
i am when i yeah i am actually i'm a
song and dance guy
maybe your dreams will come true it's
weird because it's more it's really i've
seen it it's more of a dance than a song
than a song
you know it depends what what like if
you're closer to the north or the south
pole
like if you're closer to the north pole
it's more of a dance and a song
oh okay all right uh well depends where
i am i guess when i see it jim talk to
me a little bit about peter pan and
wendy coming up
uh are you enjoying playing smee what
can you tell us about
about jude as captain hook that's got to
be pretty crazy it's
it's pretty crazy i i mean i guess i
you're maybe you're
misinformed i actually play wendy and
i but it is it's an amazing experience
it's this
classic story right and
obviously the movie is mainly about smee
thank god i mean
for years i've been waiting it's a blast
it's
uh you know it's i mean they built an
entire pirate ship and so we're like
and it's on a gimbal so we're rocking so
it's kind of when you get home you're
kind of still rocking
i'm rocking right now i believe that
that i've been on a i've been on a
houseboat and i was rocking for a couple
days
like but not in like a great way are you
okay
i just i i'm just rocking
you